you're welcome nyam welcome now didn't I
press conference and there is a present
here oh it's Noble please eat Jimmy
welcome to this press conference where
we will present this year's Nobel Prize
in Chemistry as usual we will start in
Swedish and then continue the
presentation in English when we come to
the questions you're free to pose the
question in either of these two
languages you're here d'stefano maka
stay on this security rather had become
European scoffs academia or me am i some
BC today we're at war soku-kun nagashi
mr. Graham is it the professor LED and
wood for Hyundai in Nobel Committee on
fashion me or honk as for a patrol get
clean committee and splitted be at the
aux alien Court in through the gufu
Otterbein stromae how a professor Gauna
called strim Han le the moody Nobel
Committee and Fushimi Oh honk amidst
rocks at premier implicit all its
priests handler Ahmad fleeta the CMS
experiment until silver rim dan comely
appearance cops Academy in hobbies lived
at ETL at photos and threatened or Nobel
Prize I see me till professor martin car
plus with university distress poor Frank
Ricci or Harvard University Cambridge
Massachusetts
we saw oak professor Michael Leavitt
it's Stanford University School of
Medicine Californian
we saw or professor re partial with
University of Southern California Los
Angeles
- you saw Academy is motivating leader
three Becklund that off lyrics column
with the allure for complex and shame is
gas system
this year's price is about taking the
chemical experiment to cyberspace the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences has
decided to aboard the 2013 Nobel Prize
in Chemistry to Professor Martin
Sharples at university distress pool
France and Harvard University Cambridge
Massachusetts you saw and professor
Michael Leavitt at Stanford University
School of Medicine California USA and
professor re bore shil at University of
Southern California Los Angeles USA and
the Academy Citation runs for the
development of multi scale models for
complex chemical systems so please
professor Lee Dean will you give a short
summary now in English chemistry is an
experimental science but today
theoretical chemists are providing
answers questions concerning complex
chemical reactions theoretical chemists
are working together with x-ray
mentalists to help us understand the
complex reactions in photosynthesis how
to design drugs to fit with their target
molecules in the body and how a catalyst
works in your car or in chemical
industry to model chemical reactions you
can use two completely different sites
of physics and chemistry that is the
world of quantum physics and the world
of classical physics quantum physics
allows us to look at chemical reactions
in exquisite detail but it is a method
that demands a lot in terms of computer
power and for large complex systems it
is beyond what is possible today and
will remain impossible to reach even for
the foreseeable future classical
Newtonian physics on the other hand is
relatively easy to handle and can be
used for very very large systems indeed
but these model
have the drawback that they cannot model
the making and breaking of chemical
bonds chemical reactions the natural way
to use the two is together and so what
is needed is the way to find quantum
mechanics and classical mechanics to
shake hands
as simple as that now actually
handshaking isn't all that simple and
the contributions from this year's
laureates Professor Martin cobblers
professor Michael Leavitt and professor
RA warshall is that they have provided
that secret handshake that brings a
theoretical chemistry together as one
unit
thank you professor Lee Dean and now
professor lerner Kallstrom are you ready
to give a more detailed presentation I
think it was an excellent presentation
indeed especially the final end here I
don't know if anything more needs to be
said but I'll try to do something anyway
this year's Nobel Prize laureates
as you can see happier they've done
something extraordinary that actually
made Theory an equal partner to
experiment for me as a theoretician this
was unthinkable 20 years ago so we were
always inferior to the experimentalist
they always knew what was right and we
were always saying we try to say I'm
with me but now today theory is actually
an equal partner and why has that
happened well the reason is that today
chemistry focus a lot on function and
reactions and these are issues which are
hard for experimentalist to assess
basically molecules are lazy creatures
that most of the time they don't do
anything they just swing around doesn't
do anything and then suddenly when
diarrhea everything goes quick like that
and that's very hard to study
experimentally because you look at it
and nothing happens and then suddenly
everything happens
Siri doesn't suffer from these theory
controls time theory controls everything
so we can make things do exactly what we
want and in that way theory is an
excellent complement to the experiment
and what we list right here this one
here we have a citation here and we are
next mental is there and normally the
experimental it provides a structure to
do a theoretician and the theoretician
he analyzed the structure and he
suggests reactions mechanism and sarah
gives them back to the experimental is
for verifies 2:45 to give back semesters
about new calculations that should be
done and together they climbed the
neverending stairs of chemical knowledge
so what can we do with these type of
modeling well I've just given two
examples here photosynthesis is
something which is interesting to
everybody can we solve the get the the
problem of photosynthesis we have an
infinite amount of energy available to
us or new pharmaceuticals the docking of
a protein with a drug is an extremely
important phenomena can we solve these
problems in the computer then we don't
need to do any experiments on rats or
monkeys or whatever maybe at least
couldn't do fewer so what is the problem
well the problem is indicated in this
cartoon here this guy you see her that's
meant to be Isaac Newton who did his
discoveries at the middle or end of the
17th century and his mechanics and you
see this guy here this is a cat
Schrodinger's cat and that one
represents quantum mechanics which grew
a road from 1905 to 1925 and the
important names are probably plank the
trailing around Hyson body and as you
see they do not fully agree the problem
is quantum chemistry works with wave
functions wave functions doesn't allow
to calculate position and velocity
positional speed at the same time
because that's the way quantum mechanics
eats so you can't really make them well
together not easily but this year's
Nobel Prize laureates they made it look
more like this their friends and the
trick which they introduced was they
realized that if you treat some degrees
of freedom using quantum mechanics and
some degrees of freedom using classical
mechanics then it may work if you
provide a suitable coupling between the
classical and quantum degrees of freedom
so you can look at Pony from this in
this way so to say you have that they
spent that devised methods which allow
you to concentrate the attention to the
central part which where everything
happened and that was used quantum
chemically and the for away parts was
created using classical mechanics yes as
we have done with in this picture here
with over our Laurie our founder noble
Alfred Nobel and you can see the center
of his face is clear many pixels a lot
of computer resources needed to
reproduce that whereas this far out part
which are less important I mean he is
jacket and say one that's not very
important let's compute the power is
spent on that so exactly the same thing
is done here and you say we illustrated
the quantum physics with a cat and the
classical physics with the Apple and
that would be the symbols in the future
hell and pictures that to come so what
have they done these Nobel Prize
laureates well they actually sent away a
three-step rocket the first step was
this one the second is this one I will
come back to them now you see the first
step was taken when our abortion visited
mountain calculus at Harvard in the
beginning of the 70s and together they
devised a method where they described
planar molecules because the thing they
did could only be used for planar
molecules
that is to calculate the infrared and
the UV specter of these planar molecules
and the thing which is indicated about
here and below that is what chemists
called PI electrons they they saw our
electrons which are above and below the
plane of the symbol which way and the
remaining part is the Sigma skeleton as
we say that is the nuclei and bonds
chemically the electrons which are in
the plane that was not it Molly
classically but the PI system was
modeled using quantum physics and then
actually made good success in this type
of modeling so this was the first time
anybody ever merged a quantum and a
classical world in chemistry a few years
later warshall and Leavitt wanted to
lift this restriction that it only could
be used for planar systems and I used it
to study lysozyme this is you see the
big white thing is the full protein and
this is the jello Potter is the thing
which they study which is a small part
of it and it has a catalytic effect and
what I did was that I studied the
catalytic effect of this protein and
this part here which is this part here
that was studied quantum chemically and
this the remaining the yellow part
estatic using classical mechanics and
they got insight into the mechanism of
this catalyst to this enzyme but I
didn't stop there they did something
more they cause grain the well they're
sure that you could make a
coarse-grained model where you lump
together particles you see how what we
have here is a protein chain or
polypeptide chain and atoms here what
laughs together as indicated by this
rings here so all atoms that were in one
ring with more or less one new particle
and you've got the motor which looks
like this that was a coarse-grained
model the advantage of this is that you
reduce the number of particles and when
you reduce the number of particles
simulations modeling is quicker so it's
all about making the calculations with
the minimum needed effort but getting
the maximum possible accuracy and this
for some type of application this is a
very good model so what do we gain from
this we gain understanding understanding
is something which cannot easily be
provided by the experiment but from the
calculations that we do we can say why
is this reaction proceeding what is the
reason for the reaction barrier can we
lower the barrier by some technique
maybe it has an electrostatic origin
does it require a lot of energy to bring
the reactant and the product I mean the
part to reacting molecules together
maybe okay then maybe we could put
something with facilitate that some
charge particle would facilitate that
so the immense success of this basically
is that it gives us understanding and
with that I think I should stop here and
I hopefully we have some of the laureate
on the line well we got hold of all
three laureates and then now I hope that
we have professor Marshall here with us
on the phone it's very early three
o'clock or so in the Los Angeles are you
there professor warshall yeah
congratulation so how do you feel at
this very early morning times are you
extreme extremely well that's good to
hear
I'm sitting here in the session Hall of
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
and in front of my life I think I feel
oh you see us as well
well we have a lot of persons
the media all over the world and and are
you willing to take some questions from
them very glad to do we have a question
yeah yes a little professor Marshall my
name is Maria contracts a song I'm
writing for Swedish daily newspaper
Dawkins Nieto at first congratulations
to the prize thank you very much and we
just had a presentation here what what
you have done on could you just say
something that have been easier to
understand now that he couldn't
understand before you had this usually I
say it in a more complex way but what
with what we done from what I was able
to see from the presentation of Grinnell
is to develop methods that allow how
proteins actually work because x-ray
structure being existed for some time
and it's like seeing a watch and
wondering how actually it works so in
short what we develop is a way which
require a computer to look to take the
structure of a protein and then to
eventually understand how exactly it
does what it does like if you have an
enzymes that digest food in the
structure exists you want to understand
how this is happening and then you could
use it for example to design drugs or
just like in my case to satisfy your
curiosity you had a question
hello my name is Jonah Rose I am writing
for as popular science magazine fortune
from stick congratulations to the price
I am curious about what is the work that
you're doing now presently I am now
using the eyesight in the presentation
is a simple on one hand I continue to
use this combine quantum molecular
mechanics to understand how proteins
that are responsible to transfer signals
in the cells how they exactly work so
this is like 30 percent of what I am
doing and I also use this simple
representation to understand how
molecules how molecular motors work
Kalli to understand how very complex
molecules are working so it's all the
time it's how these things are working
and every time it's for more complex
questions okay thank you very much do I
see any more questions here I don't
think so so thank you once again
professor Marshall and congratulations
we are looking forward all to see you
here in the Stockholm in December for
the Nobel Prize ceremony bye thank you
thank you very much in looking forward
yeah so now I'm turning to - to the
audience here are you are there any
questions you would like to - to post to
- to the experts here at the podium if
not a I think we will close this press
conference thank you very much for your
attention and I hope to see you all back
on Monday that 14th at 1:00 p.m. at that
time and we will announce this very
sleek spine Prize in Economic Sciences
in memory of Alfred Nobel so thank you
very much for coming
you
it's friendly Dean you mentioned that
nowadays the chemistry is in this
cyberspace I thought it's far away like
hope that chemistry is just in
laboratories well of course
chemistry is an experimental science but
what has happened over the past few
years it's it's really a fascinating
development when I was a young chemist
theoreticians would come to us with
ideas about how system behaved and if
they if their predictions would scan
with our experiments they would be happy
if the two did not agree
we were always sure that that their
teachers were wrong again today when
theoreticians come with the prediction
that we cannot prove is correct or
disprove well normally we as
experimentalists go back and check our
experiments again because it may just as
likely be we who are in the wrong today
this is how far theoretical chemistry
has come to become one of the tools I
would say of experimental science
because the sort of theoretical
chemistry that this year's laureates
have been laying the foundation for our
simulations they're really numerical
experiments that tell us a lot about how
chemical systems work so I would say to
us theory has become the new experiments
what's made the theory
in this role now definitely the
contribution of this year's laureates is
central to that because what they have
done is marrying the two worlds of
quantum physics and classical physics
quantum physics will really provide us
with all the answers that we could
possibly look for quantum physics has
the wonderful ability to stop time and
to expand space so that we can look at
the tiniest detail of a system and we
can look at this during any fraction of
time that we choose the problem is that
the demands on computer power are
immense and it's completely impractical
to use this for any system of our size
therefore we have to use classical
physics to describe the bulk of the
system and it turned out that to marry
these two is no simple matter it really
took a large concerted effort over a
number of years to show that it was even
possible which is of course what the
laureates did yes
quantum physics is one way of
parametrizing the world classical
mechanics is a completely different way
of giving a model for basically the same
system now one thing is that you can
make the two and compare them and that
works beautifully the problem is to take
one part of a system and describe it in
terms of quantum physics and another
part of the chemistry out of the system
and describe it in terms of classical
physics you then have to find the
correct boundaries to put between the
two systems
and to use the input from the classical
mechanics as boundary conditions for the
quantum mechanics and vice versa and
this means that we can look at systems
of I shouldn't say any size but we can
look at vastly more larger systems and
more complicated systems and this is of
course what we need in order to
understand the systems that chemists are
studying today huge super molecular
systems biochemical molecules large
assemblies in material science and all
these disciplines use the theory that
was that was founded by our three
laureates it is really a
cross-disciplinary part of chemistry
which goes into all the fields and
enriches the model you don't really
understand what's going on it's always a
question of complexity if you have a
simple system you can get very
dependable answers by using just
experiment but experiment and physics
sorry experiment and theory go hand in
hand we need to understand why things
happen we need to understand what makes
things happen and as guna calls from was
was explaining during during his resume
of the price the real problem is that
most chemical methods tell us about what
things look like before a reaction and
what they look like after reaction there
is a there is a classical picture of
this which is given in many textbooks of
chemistry where a chemical reaction is
likened to a piece of drama
and if you go in and make the
measurements before and after it's like
seeing the actors before Hamlet and all
the dead bodies after and then you
wonder what happened in the middle and
actually there is some interesting
action there and this is what
theoretical chemistry provides us with
the whole drama so you want to be in the
eye of the storm
absolutely what are the possible
applications of that what are the
benefits is that they're not they're not
possible they are there already today
there is not a pharmaceutical company
that doesn't have a theory division that
works on trying to predict how a
molecule will interact with the target
in the body this means that all all
development of new pharmacy
pharmaceuticals has a background in
theory when you are looking at devising
new chemical reactions when you are
trying to to create a new hard material
or a new material specific properties if
you want to optimize the electronic the
electronic properties of material the
magnetic properties of material you
always start out with theory because it
saves you so much time in the lab now
theory is not perfect you still have to
do the experiment but the predictions
that theory make are becoming so much
more powerful these days that we can
perhaps save 90% of the experimenting
and concentrate of the 10% where we know
that the most important results were
life so we save a lot of money we save a
lot of time and we save a lot of effort
by doing the theoretical homework first
it's like in the old days when everyone
told you you have to read the literature
now everyone will tell you you have to
make the calculations
so now you just sit by the computer
instead of being in the lab yes there is
there is some truth in that although of
course what happens is that we can now
turn to ever more complex systems we can
always devise a system that is so
complicated from the experimental point
of view that theorists still are
struggling to keep up with us but but on
the other hand they keep challenging us
if you look at at the physics price for
graphene for example now the
extraordinary properties of graphene
were predicted before by theorists this
is why the experimentalists trying to
make the material because it's no simple
matter to make it they tried to measure
the properties because they knew that
there was something interesting in there
and they succeeded but he was all thanks
to the theory that someone even tried
they really do